when all these other hero shooters
started emerging we had our character
based Titans alrighty right what what
you know like oh no not that it really
matters but I think everyone's kind of
realizing that the anyone can do
anything approach has limitations
it seems to be the trend these days
instead of weapon loadouts or arc
typical classes shooters place to focus
on heroes characters with distinct
personalities and ability sets of their
own there's overwatch battle born and
lawbreakers and now there's titanfall to
respawn entertainment's sequel isn't
that much of a far cry from its
predecessor the core gameplay loop
between pilots and their Titans remains
as players fight enemy humans build
their titanfall meter and Colin their
hulking behemoths from orbiting space
ships the Titans themselves are more
distinct this time around they're almost
like mechanical superheroes with
abilities lending each of them a
distinct signature the fact that we have
Titans as well that gives us a little
flexibility to be able to try one system
on one side and another to Simone the
other side so we took the character part
and put that into the Titans to sort of
bring them out give them their own roles
in their own their own play style
there's ion with a shoulder mounted
laser turret chest firing particle
cannon there's scorch with its gas mines
in flame powered grenade launcher wincor
then there's ronan a veritable robotic
Jedi with a titanium sword and phase
warping powers to boot not only do these
abilities on character to their machines
but also another layer of strategy
damage tripwire maybe
if you see a ronin rounding the corner
it's best to keep your distance if I on
sets its sights on you it's probably
best to close the gap titanfall 2 feels
just as fluid as its predecessor did in
2014 but there's more forethought
involved this time and planning is
paramount in the sequel sign fall one
was a game you were often reacting to
what was happening to you and not much
opportunity to make choices anticipate
try out theories we had to try and take
this really frenetic game and make it
learnable the easy comparisons are over
watching battleborn titles that live or
die by the quality of their characters
and the interactions between them but
there are deeper inspirations at play
respawn co-founder Vince Zampella
mentioned Street Fighter as an influence
on titanfall tues new combat learning
characters is not only pivotal for using
them but knowing how to counter them as
well outside of the characters
themselves titanfall tues pacing is also
taking out a more methodical approach
during recent demo director Steve Fukuda
pointed to the first titanfall spacing
is one of the weak points as a shooter
the game as a result the game takes some
more of a different kind of pacing more
very pacing and definitely some areas
where things are quieter as you might
have noticed it's not cranked to 11 all
the time this is more highs and lows
than I think past projects much like the
necessary patience of a hero shooter
though titanfall 2 will have down
periods giving you a chance to plan out
your moves before actually executing
lastly as multiplayer designer Todd
alderman says respawn wants players to
be more proactive this time around just
from all angles we wanted to encourage
more teamwork and more thinking ahead
like things that players to make
decision points on and strategize around
and sort of drive you to stick with your
teammates so although comparisons are
bound to other modern shooters the team
at respawn sounds confident that
titanfall 2 will deliver an altogether
different experience in its predecessor
not only in core pillars of combat but
pacing planning and execution as well
titanfall 2 may be a sequel but respawn
seems intent on making it a beast of its
own as developers as development
industry we're trying to move everything
forward and we're all trying to solve a
lot of the same problems it's really
awesome to see how every studio is kind
of tackling it and you know their own
little way but I think it's a response
to we kind of nailed that every man game
over the last 10 years now let's solve
new problems
enemy pilot destroyed
you